il n'y avait pas que des élèves comme ça
mais bien sûr ça existe et c'est pas
nouveau c'est un phénomène qui est assez
ancien qui existait déjà à l'époque où
moi-même j'étais à l'école mais on est
confronté à des élèves qui vont chercher
non identifiées le professeur en
faiblesse en situation de faiblesse et
vont
appuyer sur sur ce professeur enfin vous
mettre la pression sur le professeur de
façon coordonnée si vous voulez mais ccc
c'est un truc qui arrive en début de
carrière quand on n'a pas l'expérience
et moi j'ai fait l'erreur avec un élève
en l'occurrence
l'année dernière et ce qui se passait
c'était l'élève voyez que j'ai j'avais
pas l'autorité pour le gérer et il en
profitait tout simplement le dire quoi
en profiter il se permettait des trucs
qui le régime qui serait jamais permis
avec d'autres profs donc il va me
menacer du regard il va appuyer son
regard de façon insistante pour montrer
qu'il est en désaccord avec mon autorité
ou est ce que j'essaye de lui inculquer
à c'était assez violent d'après ce que
vous savez ce que vous dites mais les
brigitte arson s'est mis à écrire des
insultes sur les copies qui vous rendent
est un jour il vous a lancé un objet en
sortant d'un cours oui et il a convoqué
ses parents et lorsque le père de
l'élève est arrivée dans le bureau du
cpe il a giflé son enfant devant vous
mais est-ce que ça c'est la réaction des
parents mais quelle a été la réaction de
vos supérieurs de l'institution ou de
vos supérieurs dans l'école vous
enseignez à l'orb à la réaction l'été là
c'est à dire que quand on demande à une
punition l'été appliquer une sanction
pardon pas une punition donc une
sanction c'est une exclusion temporaire
ou définitive donc moi pour loger deux
stylos a vu que c'était pas la première
fois que j'avais à faire à cet élève et
que ça commençait vraiment à me poser
psychologiquement j'avais vraiment du
mal à dormir j'en faisais des cauchemars
les cauchemars de profondes y ont fait
des cauchemars de profs c'est à dire on
rêve des élèves qui nous font des des
petits diableries quad et j'essaie de
mettre dans la situation un élève qui
vous lance un objet c'est un stylo alors
en l'occurrence oui quelle est la
réaction des autres élèves ce qui
s'était passé ça va se taper il me
regarde j'étais en train de discuter
avec un autre élève l'adie de la halle
réaction instantanément c'est il voit ma
réaction moi je suis choqué il dit ça va
se taper donc moi je comprends pas ce
que veut dire je cherche à comprendre la
situation il ya un stylo qui vient de
passer
il ya le petit que j'identifie qui
dit-il a lancé derrière
voilà ce qui s'est passé c'est que j'ai
invoqué la demande d'une sanction auprès
de la principale est elle à l appliquer
donc il a été exclu le père veut nous
voir suite à ça et donc on avait rendez
vous avec la cpe la conseillère
principale d'éducation qui s'occupe de
faire le lien avec les parents puisque
c'est pas évident quand on est prof de
faire ça on a on a un autre boulot même
si ça fait partie du boulot et la cp
mais l'essentiel fluidifier sa facilité
çà et là la cpi elle n'était pas là
parce que c'est
des établissements qui sont surchargés
et donc qu'elle était en train de faire
autre chose et il se trouve qu'elle n'a
pas pu être là à ce moment là bon il se
trouve que voilà le père a giflé le fils
au final ça c'est bien bien bien passé
elle est arrivée juste après et elle a
remis les choses en place le petit
s'effondrer en pleurs le père a essayé
de comprendre ce qu'on avait à dire et
voilà derrière le gamin n'a plus posé
problème ensuite vous avez enseigné en
lycée alors ça c'était en lice et nathan
ça s'est perdu mon annonce de stage donc
été en lycée et le problème c'est que
l'année de stage dans l'éducation
nationale c'est une année où vous êtes à
mi-temps et l'autre moitié du temps un
jour par semaine donc si on peut appeler
ça une moitié de temps un jour par
semaine on va être dans une université
s'efforcer à former les profs et
ce qui s'est passé c'est que j'ai j'ai
eu ce stage en lycée sauf que l'année
une titulaire titularisation donc là où
vous avez le poste de fonctionnaire
c'était dans un collège donc quand j'ai
appris ça c'était un peu un coup de
massue parce que en fait le travail de
préparation en amont quand on est jeune
prof c'est énorme c'est vous avez vous
avez énormément de temps à consacrer à
sa les vacances elles servent à ça si
vous n'avez pas les vacances vous n'avez
pas le temps de préparer le court mais
la formation con que vous suiviez est ce
que ça comporte est la manière de gérer
ce genre d'élève comportement violent
auquel vous avez oui en théorie on alors
là en l'occurrence je pouvais pas
l'éviter c'était une erreur de débutant
j'ai repris devant toute la classe ça
l'a humiliée je suis devenu en quelque
sorte son ennemi et ils voulaient me le
faire payer d'accord donc ça je vois pas
comment on peut le transmettre à part en
limant donc les formations sont utiles
mais ça fait pas tout